ah okay two kids we're gonna doorbell
run yeah I don't care if we're not that
do so it oh we're gonna do it now that
works whatever strong independent woman
who don't need no man and apparently I
don't need no babies anymore damn better
get my kids in soccer even if I don't
have any come along little Daisy I see
you Pedley still there come on ah ah oh
[ __ ]
icy Shores oh this actually looks nice I
mean it's pretty huh no Pluto huh oh I
don't think these are the size ha ha ha
ha ha
you're rightist it's so big Saturn is so
girthy ah alright right about our time
la are you [ __ ]
Oh your paycheck [ __ ] yeah gotcha
just use the same technique entire time
Oh roll yeah mother pop oh no huh
faceball tech niche ah you can't beat
this I think I can top him suck on that
level maker muffin man 72 Wow
I just sent a piece of [ __ ] got right go
right over me thank you
hahaha way to fail buddy good job
killing yourself I'm sure your family
will be very proud of you
oh wait they're all dead ha okay not
again oh my self Oh mother oh my god ah
press space to grab the harpoon oh nah
just missed it I want it ready
your son of a [ __ ] nah milena my noggin
pesky off Wow alright now that I
actually know what I'm doing I'm gonna
grab this poon and I'm gonna Ram it with
a fist of justice
cows bullseye I can't I'll cut that okay
obstacle course
oh thanks for the boost oh no no don't
hurt
don't hurt dad don't hurt God didn't
hurt it off Dada
it's a giant ball I'm used to hit oh my
god no oh [ __ ] you ball fatality grab
this finish who was awesome ah no son
distract the ball oh come back for you
what's with all that blood now this
seems interesting I'm already dead lady
I'm so dead
challengers Road okay all right rope
swing hard version to me all of the rope
swings are hard I passed
best rope swing wait no oh yeah I'm the
greatest still greatest still greatest
still pretty damn great whoo head first
I fee first good enough ah all right
let's get oh you can't fool me Bruce oh
there we go we uh face good faith give
up I'll bow to God I don't even know how
did what do I do to fire all right you
kids you screwed up a lot time but now
we're gonna cut that's good you got it
good you're talking about
fire well I get it
ah yeah there comes my living nightmare
Oh pest I didn't need your help
ah miss me douche guys just now yo na
missed me too
you think you can kill me I'm the
scariest a ya there oh go oh hey whoa
what what am i doing what am i doing oh
my god
it's not about dad right that's what I
meant to do ha what I did but I won
that's all that matters I'm gonna get
job I'm still alive factory meet Hanif
we wore like computron is going to lag
[Music]
axé run excuse me while i jazzers haha
my head barely made it
there's nothing first again [ __ ] you and
your damn require all what uh-oh my leg
I took a didn't need that one - hey miss
me deck yours I didn't do it I'm out of
here Mike fall I'm good at these
I didn't even in my Segway hard ho go
challenge well this seems easy Oh blows
incorrect we all my first sword through
rude
Jayda mark you son of a [ __ ] you think
you could just do that and get away from
it oh you're just a fake copy of me I'll
kill you you about dirty
[Music]
and everyone except mark died just away
it's going to be normally I'm good at
these things
shut up dog
don't cry tab ready to backflip ah hard
bottle run
I hardly find these bottle runs to be
challenged now I am do I stay down there
carry on okay
Indiana Jones gonna make this look easy
hey not gonna give me I'm still here I'm
still alive
good God okay all right let's get this
correctly ah fish oh oh I'm so
professional
Oh amazingness is my name awesome
dwarfs ward throw if I could say the
words Lord but that's what need to I
knew I would tell you you gotta get a
star death all around me and yet it
escaped me night head ah Poirot death
this has been happy wheels highlights
thanks for watching if you like what
your son you want to see more why not
subscribe to my channel want to help the
channel grow
leave a like add it to your favorites or
share it with your friends on Facebook
and Twitter thanks again and as always I
will see you in the next video
[Music]